[Music]  [Applause]  know your ears don't deceive you that's  ariana grande putting her best goth rock  spin on kendrick lamar's hit humble  [Music]  she also channeled her inner 90s diva to  give us a little drink it all went down  during our ease takeover of Tuesday's  Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon where she  showed off several of her many talents  including her unexpected yet epic  impression of actress Jennifer Coolidge  god sure looked like the fourth of July  dumbass later ariana performed her  single no tears left to cry and she even  dropped some exciting news about her  upcoming album yes my album is coming  this summer it is called sweetener it's  kind of about like bringing light to a  situation or to someone's life or  somebody also brings light to your life  or sweetening the situation yeah  [Music]  [Applause]